There is a ground stop on our airport
and this thing is up in the sky.
This thing
now believe
by the United States
to be a Chinese government spy balloon
flying 60,000 feet up in the atmosphere
over the country.
We do know that the balloon
has violated U.S.
airspace and international law,
which is unacceptable.
U.S.
defense officials
have been tracking it closely
for several days, debating
whether to shoot it down
and advising President Joe Biden
it would be too dangerous.
We assess that it does not pose
a risk
to people on the ground
as it currently is traversing
the continental United States.
And so out of an abundance of caution,
Cognizant of the potential impact
to civilians on the ground
from a debris field.
Right now, we're going to continue
to monitor and review options.
The news breaking
just days
before Secretary of State
Antony Blinken was due to travel
to Beijing.
The administration's
highest level trip to China so far.
The trip now
postponed despite a rare Chinese apology
and claim that the balloon
was for civilian purposes
and floated off course.
The presence of a surveillance
balloon in U.S.
airspace is a clear violation of U.S.
sovereignty and international law.
That is an irresponsible act.
And that the PRC's decision
to take this action
on the eve of my planned visit
is detrimental
to the substantive discussions
that we were prepared to have.
The Pentagon says steps
have been taken
to protect sensitive
intelligence targets on the ground.
The balloon is the size of three busses
equipped with solar panels for power
and a surveillance payload.
Satellite and other data indicate
the balloon may have originated
in central China,
with weather patterns
pushing it out
over the Pacific Ocean into Canada
and down into the United States,
where it has been crossing Montana
and into Missouri.
It can maneuver itself
and has changed course.
Currently floating over the central U.S.
officials say,
while offering
little more on its precise location,
the public certainly has the ability
to look up in the sky and
and see where the balloon is.
And they have
curiously training eyes
and cameras towards the skies.
What planet is that
And, Jake, Secretary Blinken
has said
that he will reschedule his trip
to Beijing as soon as conditions allow.
What those conditions are,
they will not say
but clearly
the temperature needs to come down.
We just heard Secretary Blinken say now
the number one priority
is to get this balloon
out of our airspace.
The Pentagon believes
that this could be several
more days, in fact.
So they will keep watching it
as it floats on
by keeping their options open Jake.
All right.
Alex Marquardt at the U.S.
State Department for us.
Thank you so much.
Let's bring in CNN
senior international correspondent
Ivan Watson in Hong Kong.
CNN national security
correspondent Kylie
Atwood and CNN aviation
correspondent Pete Montaigne.
And, Pete,
I want to start with your brand
new reporting.
You're learning
that pilots are reporting,
seeing this balloon during their flights.
Well, it is only a matter of time
before pilots
started spotting this, Jake.
They're flying at high altitudes.
And what's so interesting
is that they're reporting this balloon
only a few thousand feet above them.
Look at this report
from the crew of a Cessna Citation.
Private jet flying at 43,000 feet.
They said
derelict balloon adrift at 50,000 feet.
Only a 7000 foot difference there.
They reported that
not all that long ago
near the Kansas City, Missouri
International Airport.
What is also so interesting here
is that the Pentagon says
the balloon was cruising at 60,000 feet.
So there's a question here
about whether or not
this balloon is descending.
Remember,
airliners are typically at an altitude
of about 30,000 feet.
So the other big question here
is whether or not
this balloon will descend
and have more of an impact
on commercial air travel in the U.S..
We have already seen
that happen once before. On Wednesday.
There was a ground stop
and flights were diverted
from about a 200 mile swath of airspace
between Helena and Billings, Montana.
We know that lasted for 2 hours.
Now, the question is
whether or not
there will be more ground stops
because of this
and how this balloon
will descend to the ground.
Will it pop
or will it come down gracefully?
Remember, what goes up comes
has to come down, Jake and Ivan.
Secretary Blinken's trip
to China has been postponed.
No future dates have been announced.
We should note, it's
not often that a visit
to such a significant
adversary is made
by a secretary of state,
much less canceled.
It seems like a fairly significant
diplomatic breach here.
Absolutely.
This is a big deal.
And the relationship between the U.S.
and China
have really soured
over the past couple of years.
This trip
by Blinken was supposed to be building on
a meeting between
President Biden and the Chinese leader,
Xi Jinping, in Bali
at the G-20 summit in November.
The Biden administration
had been complaining
that Chinese officials
simply weren't talking to U.S.
officials
and there had been an agreement
to reopen lines of communication
and try to build guardrails to
to prevent the world's
two largest economies.
The tensions from spiraling,
spiraling out of control.
So now you have this serious incident,
which Blinken we just heard him
speaking from Korea,
calling it
irresponsible,
a violation of international law,
a violation of U.S.
airspace and sovereignty,
but also saying, hey,
we've been able to communicate
directly about this
to prevent the tensions
from spiraling out of control.
That seems to be paying some dividends
right now.
At the same time, though,
the Biden administration has said
we cannot have this visit
at this time,
that this is going to be a distraction
and there's a major problem here.
So I do think we're seeing some results
of that diplomacy right now.
The big question,
what to do about this balloon,
and I'm sure that U.S.
security officials
would love to get their hands
on the technology
that the balloon is carrying right now.
Yeah, indeed.
And quite
clearly, the Pentagon confirmed today
this is not the first time
a surveillance balloon
has appeared over the United States,
but but previous instances
were not made public.
So why is this time different
just because people in the public saw it?
I think that's part of it.
I also think the fact that it happened
on the eve
of the secretary of state's planned
visit is also quite consequential here.
We heard that from senior State
Department officials today saying,
yes, this has happened before,
but this is happening before this
major visit
that we had all been planning for.
We don't think that visit can now be
as productive as we had hoped.
That's why they're pulling it down.
We heard just now
from the secretary of state saying that
the decision to take
this action is detrimental
on behalf of China.
What that indicates
is that the United States
believes that it was deliberate,
that China actually allowed
or sent
this spy balloon over the United States,
perhaps it was even deliberate
that it happened right before this trip
was going to go ahead
sort of to test the United States.
The other thing that he said
is that the United States right
now is focused
first and foremost
on getting this spy balloon out of U.S.
airspace.
What they're asking China to do.
We really don't know.
But he didn't count out
any additional repercussions
for China as a result of this,
you know, violating U.S.
sovereignty
other than pulling down this trip Jake.
And Ivan, on CNN earlier
today, the former secretary of defense
under Donald Trump Mark Esper, said
he finds it
curious that the Chinese government
is making excuses
instead of outright
denying that it's their balloon.
What do you make of how Chinese officials
are handling this?
I'm really stunned, actually.
I mean, I've been based here in Hong
Kong for more than seven years, Jake.
I've never heard the Chinese government
expressing regret
over its actions before,
something akin to an apology right here,
basically coming out and saying,
yes, this is our balloon
and it's flown off course.
They've they've
claimed that it is a meteorological
balloon,
which, of course,
the Pentagon has challenged
that description of
of this of this thing.
But it is a far cry from the tone
that we have typically heard
in past
years, this so-called wolf
warrior diplomacy
that's coming
out of the Chinese government
and Chinese officials
where they're aggressive
and nationalistic in
and pounce on things instead here.
There is acknowledgment
that this is theirs.
Maybe part of this
has to do with the fact
that Americans can see this thing with
the naked eye we just
the Chinese government is very opaque.
So it's hard to know
what could be the motivation
for sending this thing up in the air
at this time. Is it deliberate?
Is it, in fact,
an accident
that this thing blew off course?
But it is a huge symbol right now.
And it's not just affecting the U.S..
China has summoned the.
Sorry, Canada has had to summon
the Chinese ambassador there
because it flew through Canadian airspace
as well.
So it does look embarrassing,
I could argue, for the Chinese government
to have this giant thing floating around,
especially when China
makes such a big deal
about infringements
on its own national sovereignty
and accuses the US of this
almost on a daily basis.
And Kylie,
you spoke to some family members
of one of the Americans currently
wrongfully detained in China,
and they were closely watching Secretary
Blinken's trip to Beijing
to see if their cases
were going to be brought up.
They must be very disappointed
in some ways.
Of course,
this was an opportunity for them.
They were really hoping
that the secretary of State
was going to raise
all three Americans
who were wrongfully detained in China
in these meetings and potentially,
you know,
get some action on some back
and forth to try and get their release.
But as we have seen
in US-China relations,
when there's one bad thing,
it often happens to have ripple effects
on other efforts
that they're trying
to get going underway.
So this is not a good thing
for these families.
Pete Montaigne,
Ivan Watson, Kylie
Atwood, thanks so much. The.